- [Narrator] This Bitcoin mining facility
in upstate New York,
home to thousands of
computers running nearly 24/7
is just five miles from Niagara Falls,
near one of the largest
sources of hydro electricity
in the US.
At the facility, workers
are attempting to build
a more sustainable way
to mine for Bitcoin,
a process that has
generated a lot of criticism
for the amount of energy it consumes.
Recent data estimates that globally
it consumes over a hundred terawatt hours
of electricity annually,
or more than the country of Finland.
In 2018, one study estimated
that in less than 30 years,
emissions from Bitcoin mining alone
could push up global warming
above two degrees Celsius
and recent crackdowns on
cryptocurrencies in China
are putting an even bigger spotlight
on the environmental
impact of the industry.
- You have this Bitcoin mining
sector that is very hungry
for innovation and
technological solutions.
- Bitcoin miners around the
world are making changes
that they say will make the
process more sustainable,
both environmentally and financially.
Here's a look at how this
transformation is playing out.
The facility in Niagara Falls
is owned by Bit Digital and BlockFusion,
two crypto mining companies
that are harnessing the power of water
to cut down on their operations emissions.
- This place was founded as a coal factory
to power a tire company.
And this was decommissioned and repurposed
into a Bitcoin mining facility,
not using fossil fuels,
but instead using Niagara Falls
and using that clean source of
power to power this facility.
- Sam Tabar helps run Bit Digital,
a member of the Crypto Climate Accord,
which aims to transition
the crypto industry
to net zero greenhouse
gas emissions by 2040.
- We intend to be a
hundred percent renewable
way before then.
We're about half renewables now,
and in the next few months,
we'll be dramatically
increasing that percentage.
- According to Tabar,
this facility which runs
largely on renewable hydro-power
is almost entirely carbon neutral.
The process starts here
at the Robert Moses Niagara Power Plant,
where water from the Niagara
River run through 13 turbines
to produce renewable electricity.
This is then transported
through high voltage transmission lines
to Bit Digital's facility,
where it powers a warehouse
of mining machines.
The computers use Bitcoin's
proof of work method,
which burns huge amounts of energy.
This process is part of
how the cryptocurrency
builds its blockchain,
which is key to keeping it
decentralized and secure.
Around the world powerful
computers work simultaneously
to guess a complex sequence of numbers
to validate a block of transactions.
The miner whose computer gets there first,
is awarded Bitcoin.
This transaction is recorded
on the blockchain ledger,
which is essentially
a digital record book.
While secure,
proof of work needs large
amounts of processing power
simply because it requires
all of the mining computers
to work on the same puzzle.
- These math problems are very complicated
and they'll only increase in difficulty
as more and more miners
come into the system.
So there's no debate that it
takes a lot of electricity.
The debate is where that source
of electricity comes from.
- The process to unlock new
Bitcoins also has limits.
Right now,
over 18 and a half million
Bitcoins have been mined
out of a maximum 21 million.
And the more miners that seek
out those remaining coins,
the more energy intensive
the process becomes.
This is what is driving concern
over electricity consumption
in the crypto industry.
- It is true that it is energy intensive.
However, it's all about
the sources of energy.
If you use clean sources of
energy, it's not a problem.
If you're using dirty
sources, that's a problem.
- While renewable sources of energy
release less CO2 into the
atmosphere than fossil fuels,
experts say that hydropower facilities
can still have harmful impacts
on ecosystems and biodiversity.
Bitcoin mining, both
renewable and non-renewable,
also generates electronic waste
an estimated 11.5 kilotons per year.
Bit Digital also runs a
number of other operations
that use renewables,
such as this solar powered
mining site in Nebraska.
Other Bitcoin miners in the
US are eyeing nuclear power
and countries like Iceland
are home to operations
using geothermal energy.
Tabar says,
that along with his company's
transition to renewables,
Bit Digital is ramping up
operations in North America,
partly a reaction
to their recent regulatory
crackdowns in China.
For years, the company, like
many other crypto miners,
ran part of its business out of China.
But just months ago,
the country effectively
banned Bitcoin mining,
which has driven many in the industry
to rapidly move operations
to other countries
like the US, Canada and Kazakhstan.
- It's been a great thing
for the United States
because all this innovation
in the power sector
is happening as a result of this ban.
The focus on finding
renewable sources of power
and creating technological solutions
to create further efficiencies.
- For Tabard,
transitioning the crypto
industry to renewable energy,
isn't just for the good
of the environment.
It also has financial benefits.
- I don't think investors
are keen to invest in
Bitcoin mining companies
that are not looking at
cleaner sources of power.
That is not the right investment to make.
We want to be profitable,
but we don't want to destroy
the earth while we're at it.
- While critics remain skeptical
of the crypto industries' energy demands,
the push for a more
sustainable mining future
continues to pick up steam.